thank you avocado
Latina addictions
on
[Applause]
um
linked
and finally when I switch to English I
hope that everyone will understand and
everyone will finally
understand exactly what I want to say
and only remember that before
in all those languages it was well he
was trying to fill those 40 minutes time
that he has for his talk and he just
speaks to us and we want to see want to
hear The Melody of his voice but well
nothing more
um this is very important to have such
content that looks like content but
doesn't mean anything to you and
probably the text that you know and that
you expect that I'm going to show you
now
is this Lauren ipsum
and you know it's so well that now I can
tell you that maybe there are two typos
and let's say you have 40 minutes to
find them
thank you
Ricardo tells me that I should talk
maybe about myself but he said already
everything but well okay let me tell you
a little bit about myself so I was born
in Czechoslovakia
there are many people who say that
Czechoslovakia well it doesn't exist
anymore
but well I was not born now I was born
more than 30 years ago and for those
younger who have never used python 2.5
and don't know what Czechoslovakia is
let me tell you that well we are now
here in Berlin that is Germany well well
East West well sorry so you're in Berlin
now there is Germany and in those times
there was East Germany and West Germany
and Berlin was also East Berlin and West
Berlin and Czechoslovakia was here
but it was like like from here until
here and there was something are you
following me
so there was Soviet Union behind it and
um and then from Czechoslovakia when we
wanted to go to see there was Baltic Sea
and there was Adriatic
are you
you are still looking for the typos
okay
so and
well that was all the history but
then I studied somewhere in France lived
in Germany Austria now I'm in Austria
and my job is actually as Ricardo said
using python to make the sunshine and
the wind blow because well I'm writing
some python code and make those big
things not run but they run and analyze
all the data and predict and forecast
and intercast and uh do plenty of stuff
with them
um
well if you want to move to the talk of
course there are always there is always
something or sort of disclaimer and I
have now prepared this well this is the
only site that I have not prepared I
have asked this words that nobody
pronounced so it's uh to write this text
for me but well nobody reads uh terms of
service so let's just click on proceed
accept
ah okay now it works
so
you have seen this Laura mipson text and
now let's
test our virtual software that is
responsible to put this text into some
column because nobody reads columns like
that you know why latte always makes the
columns narrow because people are able
to read up to 70 or 80 characters in a
line before they switch to the next line
you cannot just read text across the
whole screen
and it looks good you can recognize at
the beginning this floram ipsum so
well our software works until
we write another paragraph in German
well you see that there is one word that
is a little bit longer it means that
actually our test has failed because the
text is this word is too long and our
software doesn't support uh word like
well
uh splitting more splitting
and there is also another problem but
for that you cannot look at the text
like this you have to really see the
text in the original form and this is
this
our software doesn't support umlauts
and that's why lorem ipsum is not good
placeholder text for your German French
Slavic hunger and text because you don't
know whether the um outs are working
so you see that in this case there was a
fallback attack fallback fallback font
that shows all the um louds in a
different uh
like Italy case for this example so you
have to know that you cannot use lorem
ipsum for your text
and this is not only German well you
recognize actually immediately that it
is German because of the long words
and now we are already trained to to
recognize the languages only looking at
them like this
so this is an extract from a big
dictionary that contains some very
malicious errors and now you can tell me
okay the first sentence is in English
the second one is actually the other
language of that dictionary that I'm
talking about and you will recognize
what I'm talking about the second
language is Hungarian you see already a
letter A words that are a little bit
longer the third one who knows the
German of course very long words the
first one the words are a little bit
shorter there are less vowels and there
are there is some noise around the
letters looks like check
the fifth one
many short words what is it
I will show you the next one
you see these punches in the face with
the square characters black ones that
looks like Chinese and the next one is a
little bit lighter you see the
structures that is Korean and the last
one who knows
that's Burmese
so you see that you have already
immediately like you see the text and
you can recognize which language it is
even without knowing the verse and or
knowing the script
probably many of you know that this
comes from a dictionary that was Arenas
actually the second phrase should be
something like I would like to buy a box
of matches
um translations are difficult
they are difficult but
you have you cannot translate the words
exactly how they are sometimes you need
to add some context to them who knows
the book Little Prince little petite
friends and to understand exitary I also
have this book
at home in the chapter 4 or there is a
short paragraph about
about adults who cannot who don't
understand if you tell them oh I have
seen a house with red bricks and flowers
and everything you have to tell them
I've seen a house that costs 100 000
Francs
and they then they understand and now if
you randomly take these different
language versions of this book not all
houses are at the same price
most of them cost 100 000 but sometimes
in Netherlands they cost Garden in the
the cheapest house are in Italy there
are 100 000 lira I don't have a
translation with Euro until now
and I think in Turkey they cost already
in direction of uh of millions so if you
translate text then of course you have
to set it into some context context is
very difficult this is not the content
that this context is taking
um also for such translations this is my
backpack very nice backpack the only
problem is I don't know where it has
been produced because the first line
says it has been made in Vietnam but but
all other languages said it has been
produced in China
sometimes you shouldn't even exaggerate
it with translations
so this is can you recognize the
languages
I would say the first one uh looks like
English the second one with the
uppercase H that must be German and the
third one
we that's right
I'm really wondering that they called it
USB and not the SU
with all their abbreviations like Union
universe
[Music]
and even in technical senses like I have
studied Computer Sciences in France even
some technical abbreviations are
inversed
any Finnish speakers here
I always wanted to know what's means
you can put it into Google translate or
some people or whatever but
these translations are sometimes wrong
what you have seen before with this
backpack made in China Vietnam and so if
a few years ago you tried to translate
some sentences in Google Translate and
for example it was the sentence
I speak English
it has been translated into German as
president
so always in the local language why
because the usually this machine
learning
takes the materials from many official
resources and where are good official
resources these are for example the
texts of the low text of the European
Union
and you have a long English text that
has been really very correctly
translated into French but on the top of
the English text is English version
and on the top of the French text is
Frances and the Machine thinks okay
English Francis so I have to translate
it this way
this sentence is probably nothing
nothing special in Finnish but if you
translate it to some other language for
example check
we will understand why checks don't use
random password generators they throw
darts at books
so put your finger in your throat
and this sentence has been chosen and
translated into other languages in an
open source open data portal called
tatoreba.org anyone knows
I strongly recognize recommend you to
have a look at it if you if you want to
learn another language or you are
interested in
and you would like maybe even to
contribute because this is what I would
like to encourage you to do
um this portal
is
a collection of sentences of many
sentences in any language and what
people do they go there and they have an
account and they say okay I am a native
speaker of let's say in my case Trek and
Slovak and I speak at good level I mean
English German French and so on and then
it shows me sentences that have been
random sentences that have been written
in for example English and that are
missing a chegor Slovak translation and
with my human ability to translate into
my native language I can translate it
and edit there so I have added already a
few thousands or hundreds of sentences
and you can also use this website also
to search for a word
and this is open data it means that if
you want to write a software that needs
a lot of data in both languages or more
languages you can download you can tell
I want a pair of
German and Swahili or Turkish and
Estonian and it will find all sentences
that have been translated by someone in
both languages and you will can download
a CSV file with all these sentences
they are not 100 correct but well
people are people they make errors and
there may be some of course some errors
but you can improve them if you uh speak
the your language of course at the
native level
but I have said contact this King
this is completely wrong sentence
you cannot walk out of this room go to
some shop here in Berlin and tell this
to a shop assistant
there is one word that is missing
what did your mother tell to you before
always use that word
for those few who don't well there are
of course people who don't understand
German
this means this
so if you you read it like be in hell
and it just means I would like those
maybe shoes in a brighter color
you cannot imagine how many words are
there out there that Tom that means
something else in a different context
so
we have 26 okay for example in Slavic
language we have 43 letters but
count with me how many different words
can you produce using
five six seven eight letters so it's 26
to the power of six that's not that much
and it has to be pronounceable so I
don't mean about check but I mean it has
to be pronounceable
um and there is one website called
dictionary
where you can just type a Word a
sequence of letters and it will tell you
a list of all languages where you can
find this word with all grammatic uh
antonyms synonym
etymology
of all cases and everything else for
example in our case
the in hell can mean also something else
in different languages I find it very
interesting I don't speak Norwegian but
in Norwegian all three words mean
something yeah
they D or die is to breastfeed the
second word in in many languages means
like it is in fashion and the last one
uh hell means luck in Norwegian
so you see that context context is very
important and you have if you see some
words you cannot just tell okay this is
a stop word because in some other
language it can mean something normal
you cannot tell someone who whose last
name means maybe something offensive in
your language this can be a normal word
in other language and
there it is their rights to be named
like that names of people cannot be
invalid
um let's go back to English this is
normal English phrase but even if you
cannot probably read the verse exactly
you see that there is one exactly one
word that looks differently
why
you think
you can read that because on screen I
cannot read it that okay so now you see
now you see that there are two types of
highlighting there is bold and italic
and bolt is something that has to be
visible immediately in the whole text on
the whole page so you'll see the page
and if it is bold you see it immediately
so if you want to highlight something
only when reading please use italic
there is also other sort of syntax this
is also English sentence but you see
that the first letter
it's not capital
why
because and this is something that you
will see also in documentation technical
documentation there are plenty of
products of projects that are lowercase
and even if they are in the beginning of
the phrase they are written in lower
case
and if we move from Human languages to
programming languages you look at it and
you can immediately recognize which
programming languages are that the first
is Python 3 the second one without
parenthesis that's python 2 then we have
shell C and the last one okay I was not
so nice but that's you know that's Java
it's a little bit more verbose
um this was uh without seeing too much
you'll see the first one is assembler
the second one
brain fact and now comes the third one
that is not uh hello world
but may mean something different what is
this
that's Pearl very probably
because statistically 93 percent of
paint Splitters are valid pro programs
there was someone who ran OCR over these
images and
damage is very valid
okay so that was enough fun now let's
get something serious to some
programming uh if you want random data
we need of course some random number for
example at the beginning let's start
with numbers some random number
generator
it works it is not python but it works
uh all the time
if we want to do something like that in
Python of course from the standard
Library import random and then random
Rend int and you get a random integer so
ah
and this
rent in explicitly returns a random
integer between beginning and end or you
can use rent range and it doesn't
include the end because integers
are no problem they are
every one step there is one integer and
if I say I want between one thousand and
two thousand there are a thousand
integers and I get that
but there is no rent float and sometimes
I need a rent float why is there no rent
float function
because you don't want to get a random
float number
random float numbers are not divided
uniformly
a random or a float number a 64-bit
number
um is stored in the computer using 64
bits the first one is for plus minus
then exponent exponent says in which
sector of one two two four four eight
sixteen or the other way around like
between half and one quarter and half
and so on we are the the number is
stored and fraction is uh very quite
exact place within this sector so it
means that if I say I want a random
number between 0 and 1 random float then
between half there are exactly as many
float numbers between 0 5 and 1 s
between zero zero zero zero something
and zero zero zero zero something a
little bit more so you don't want a
random number you want to use uniform
and that explicitly says it I give you
some random some float number that
represents some number that is between
minimum and maximum
and of course it is very important to
take the right type number type for uh
for your needs so for example if you
have number of items that you have to
use integer or fraction remember there
are 60 minutes in an hour not 60.0
minutes in an hour you needed that in
Python 2 because you cannot divide 100
minutes by 60 because then you receive
an integer one now if you divide integer
by integer you get a float so that's
what you want
floats are for measurements or physical
measurements of units where you don't
mind whether this table is one meter or
one meter and zero zero one micron at
all
and the most important things that can
cost you a lot of money are the finances
what type are you going to use for
finances
no
exactly what the rtex authorities use
you want to get exactly the same sense
at the end as they get and then it's
fine you don't want it's not it doesn't
matter that you lose sense at the
beginning you don't want to lose
thousands at the end
about the measurements in the units well
we have meter but meter is also
approximately and this is in one Museum
in central Germany uh Museum of
measurements where you pay entrance
according to your weight or you pay flat
rate so you can decide whether you want
to be weighted at the beginning or you
just pay a little bit more and these are
all the else I think it is called else
like the length in different cities in
Germany many years ago so every city had
their own standard
before they moved to meter
um we if we want to get some random
numbers we usually don't want to get
numbers in between
minimum and maximum exactly for example
this is a height distribution of some
persons in some country no matter what
and the blue line would be like I want
random numbers between 140 and 180 but
the population doesn't look like that it
looks more like the red line so many
people are in the middle and some are
taller smaller but most people are
somewhere in the middle
and for that there is a random not
random uniform but random girls and with
the new and sigma you can get these
numbers quite well in the other
direction if you want actually to get
this mu and sigma for this because
the
what is it called
standard
then
[Music]
you can use the statistics module and
give all the Heights and it will it will
give you this these two numbers
um
then we have some other events for
example we have some events so there are
some events for example 240 events per
eight hours and we would like to know
how often something happens
this means that of course there is one
customer or one event every two minutes
and for that there is again something in
random module explore variate where you
say 1 divided by the length of each uh
average event and this will give you the
distribution how often something happens
and there are plenty of other
models or other functions that will give
you
good functions to get the information
that you need use them use them try to
learn them try to learn some a little
bit of statistics and
use the right model
for your job all models are wrong but
some models are useful
now we want to get a little bit to the
gdpr so we want to use names and you
cannot just take a phone book from
somewhere and use it in your test
let's take the most common names in
Germany male female last names uh places
the most popular name places and we want
to find some persons so you can take
like sample give me a sample of five
cities and it will give you five cities
but how many people are here from Berlin
there is not one person from Berlin
there are maybe many people from Berlin
many people from
whatever name
so name and position City and so on it
is not the primary key
there can be several Noah Mueller from
Berlin or Emilia Schmidt from cone
that's why you want to take choices it
means that you allow more
places to get one place several times
but again there are probably not seven
people from Lincoln here so there are
more people from Berlin we want to have
some population weight and in that case
you can use the choices and the
attribute parameter rates that gives you
for example the population so we have
more people from bigger cities
look like that looks nice but people
have different names
and
and my name is my name cannot be invalid
but you see that you you have also to
take into account names that look a
little bit differently and print them
correctly
and even names that look like ASCII
short not short not too short not too
long but still they
maybe uh uh May across problems to
Airlines because usually they put Mr at
the end for misters but they don't know
if the person is already called Amer
should they put it there or not
names of places like
are also some extreme cases
and now if you want to find such a place
then of course you can go to take this
but well I wouldn't do that because you
see Rwanda and Burundi over 20 million
inhabitants they cover six square
degrees and on the South Pole where
there is almost non-population you see
only here 360 360 or 1000 of squares of
such squares so if you'd get a random
position then this can be this can be
really wrong
um and but for that there are maps
online well you don't want to use some
commercial Maps because all you can do
is they're like click somewhere and it
navigates you there you want to use some
better Maps there is open stream map
openstreamap is not a map it's a
database
and what you see here this is probably
what you see when you go to
openstreetmap
um there is something but there is much
more in it you can open a map that is
for cyclists with the information about
all the tracks about the safety on the
tracks Bridges and accessibility for
bicycles you can have a look at a pen
file that's like public transport maps
with exact routes and position of stops
then very technical maps of Railways
with all the details about speed about
the switches then 3D maps of
of cities because
the buildings also their information
about what is in the buildings
about the technical infrastructure power
plants
and
cmaps this is a nice map for people who
want to drive bike on
uh curving rows because it can calculate
actually from the data how the road
looks like this is for wheelchair so you
know which places are accessible and
also you have some routing and this is
our very strong routing because it you
can Define exactly what you want you
want to go by steps you want such uh
paved roads not pave roads and it will
show you exactly where to go whether you
are on bicycle walking or motorbike or
something like that
so this is everything is in the map like
in the database and there are plenty of
services that just extract the
information that they need even on apps
on your phone you can have that and
there is a website where you can extract
this information so for example this is
my favorite institution are all the
addresses and I wanted to see what are
the names of the hairdressers here in
Berlin
well there are really some nice names
that people give to their companies
and here you say okay you won in Berlin
it should be a note that has attribute
shop address and I want the name and it
shows it
then here even on that picture of
overpass turbo you can ask for for a map
of all banks in Berlin
all police stations
and you can combine this information
Banks police stations no you want them
far away from each other
and here are all the banks that are more
than two kilometers from the nearest
police station
this is Vienna beautiful city anyone has
been to Vienna
oh okay so you know there are plenty of
restaurants
so you can ask to find all the
restaurants and there are plenty of
attributes like do they have internet
microbrewery oh there are not so many
breweries but they have toilets of
course toilets internet uh vegan so some
sorts of Cuisine and so on and maybe
okay something that I would wish to ask
open stream map and that even works if
you ask all the restaurants in Vienna
that will serve brown sauce on your
schnitzel
it's wonderful
okay now let's do some interaction
who now who thinks how many stop signs
like the stop the octagonal stop signs
are there on public roads in Paris who
thinks there are more than 100 clap
300 clip once
700 1000
that is better than eBay three thousand
four thousand
okay that was the right answer there are
none
and Paris this is like I mean Paris like
really the city not the surroundings but
this is really like that
um a few years ago I was at the
conference invited to a postgrad school
conference in Paris and they told me oh
you have why we have a nice hotel for
you this code like this
really there is a hotel called Hotel
Paris France uh you cannot find it
normal looking normally on booking or
whatever but open Street maybe you say I
want a hotel that is named Hotel Paris
France and you will find it
French they really love hotels because
there are hotels of the company DeVille
no this is City Hall Hotel DeVille is
City Hall Hotel the police is a police
station and Hotel dia is a hospital
uh at the beginning of open street map I
have actually seen many foreign mappers
who just entered all these institutions
like accommodation places
uh sometimes it is of course difficult
to navigate
and sometimes it can be even difficult
to find the right place this is
definitely not in Paris
but hey I'm not talking only what
openstream can do for you I want you to
do something for openstream the minimum
that you can do you can go to
openstreamnab.org look around your place
you know and if you see something in the
map that doesn't work that is wrong then
you just click on the Green Plus add
note new note and then you click there
and you write a note so of course
the highway the motorway not found the
city nearby also not found
um
and also you shouldn't map everything
that looks like a Motorway
this is Pastor for Autobahn near Vienna
you can also if you want to like walk
around it that's fine for for the health
you can go to
or at an app called Street complete for
Android and it will just show you your
surroundings and it will ask you
questions about information that is
already in the database but it is not
complete there are some things missing
like opening times of shops the surface
of some roads and so on or if also for
iPhone there is every door app on the
right side that you can really
edit a lot of stuff
um random shuffle that means that well
this is again programming uh if you want
to use uh python to shuffle to randomly
shuffle your list then there is a short
there is a limit because of course you
can Shuffle like one two three four five
six elements but then it increases
quickly
and this is a factorial and there is a
limit if your list is more than 2080
elements then it will get to the limit
of random number generator and you will
not be able to get any combination of
them because there is merge and twister
and this is the number that python is
using and this is actually the maximum
number of combinations that you can use
in your generator random number
generator and after all this is
extinguished it will start again from
zero so
just don't forget that after a few years
centuries of running your programs it
will return the same numbers
for data you shouldn't do that like
random months here and so on because
every month is a different length and
there are leap years and everything just
do random number timestamp in UTC not in
local time and then convert it to your
local time because well time Stone time
zones are difficult these are all the
worldwide time zones uh if you look at
if you look at it like this zero is uh
Greenwich to the west to the East and
this is over the past over one century
every time zone that has moved with all
the summer time and so on
if you do prepare data with times then
make sure that this is consistent this
is a motivational poster with four young
people standing around the decks looking
somewhere and doing some project
management their watches are not
synchronous if you do give your models
uh expensive watches then make sure that
they show the same time
who remembers this what does this
program do this is not python this is
Commodore basic and this was the
cheapest program to create a random maze
you can do that in python as well
maze is also like some nice test data to
to test for example for pass searching
if you remember Roller Coaster Tycoon
um if you created something like this
then at every Crossroads the person with
very large probability was returning an
ever going further if you do it larger
longer it can take more time
more time until very long very long time
um colors
don't do random colors the RGB do they
in HSV and then convert them because
this is something more natural for us or
go to color names.org where we have uh
all the six all this well the 16 million
colors you can find the color and then
people can give names to these colors so
for example one very famous color is C
zero ffee and people have given its its
names so if you need some random names
for colors or you search for example for
python for the word python then it will
find some colors that are called after
python maybe after logo or something
different
and if in your code you really need some
random data there are two nice libraries
called Faker and minuses both of them
work in a similar way you just say in
which language you want some random data
and it will give you like names of
names addresses numbers
produces job descriptions
telephone numbers email addresses and so
on
No Limits this works similar and there
is still something that you can do
actually because if you look here this
is uh the piece of code that generates
the names of companies in German they
only take last name or two last names
and Company suffix but if you want to
create companies name for example and
everything in big letters then of course
it's better to it's possible actually to
add such functionality there so if you
want to contribute then do that
Okay so
we have faked almost everything can we
fake really everything
you can fake videos pictures music
everything there is one thing that
modern science has no answer to
it's really computationally very
difficult to fake
password
we are coming to the end
so
it's your job
to write code
to prepare the test data
be responsible for that and try to
understand what you are working on what
the data is where it comes from
um the there are of course tools or even
some
services that give you any data that you
want in any form but
if you leave it to them then you don't
have the power over what you are working
on and what you want to accomplish
and the best about our job is that we
are paid to learn the whole time
so that's the fun thank you very much
thanks Miro for a nice presentation we
didn't get any questions in uh slido I
maybe I forgot to mention that we are
using today as well
but so try to reach you if you raise
your hand if you have any questions I'll
go to you
so we have a still five minutes for
questions or I am around
the whole days I would be happy really
to
speak about the topic
we have one here
uh what is it you're working on right
now and what would you work on if you
could choose anything
is the camera on
and there are plenty of
things but I'm playing a lot with in my
free time playing a lot with the open
street map like searching for
consistencies inconsistencies in the
data
and what's nice about that is also that
I don't do it only on my computer at
home but I also get to the places so for
example that little piece of the
motorway it was really randomly I was
driving around and it was written like
future excavations future archaeologies
of course it was like an artwork but it
was a nice idea in the middle of nothing
like to create a whole with uh with a
Motorway so this way
it's possible to go to nice places and
if one could be even paid for that
anyone else have questions I see there's
some coming slider now don't be shy you
can ask
no hands so let me go for the first one
in slido
how did you learn so many natural
languages
some people have many stars in GitHub
some people sit at home and or sit at
home or travel a bit and
well okay my as I told my father tongue
is Drake my mother tongue is Slovak
which means that all surroundings are
bigger languages so for me it is like
really big exception or a surprise even
now if I meet someone who is a foreigner
who is learning trigger slow again
speaks it as a good level because I am
actually used to to the most widespread
language in the world like my bad
English or German and so and
that's why people from such countries if
they live abroad a little bit are more
motivated to to learn their local
language and
not to think that everyone understands
Slovak
where are the typos in the lower Apes
but I was like glad to see that you got
interested in that and people are really
like looking and then and searching for
the typos
I'm I keep going for the slide though
um what do you find the hardest about
wind power forecasting
um it's sometimes when you like drive to
the in the countryside
in near Vienna there are plenty of them
in the direction of Hungarian and Slavic
border there are hundreds of them and
when you see that some of them are still
like not moving some of them are moving
at different speed
you're thinking that okay everything
that I calculated is wrong because I
cannot know whether something is going
to happen and to be maintained and
whether they are going to work it or not
do you miss anything from the good old
times of python 2.5
I will never be that young again
are you an NLP expert
what is NLP
um one none it's lots of questions
coming on
uh how do you make the sunshine with
python
uh well there are wind turbines and
there are some solar panels that have to
be maintained and
worked on as well
um let me see one more question what's
the next Hot Topic in Python that you
personally want to dig
the next feature of heightened
the next Hot Topic a hot topic of
partner
where is when is the next pie candy
we'll have some time for that we'll find
something
I'll take one more question
let me see here do you know the meaning
of your last name yes
and if you look at me you will recognize
it immediately in Czech and Slovak it is
a normal verb that means gray-haired
all right middle
thank you yeah